there's that scene where Bob De Niro is
standing at the bar with a cigarette and
he's looking at Manny and he's going to
kill him and you know he's going to kill
him and Marty has this shot
and he gets closer and closer and closer
and Bob's eyes get more wolf-like we
shot that I think at 32 frames a second
or 36 frames this is the most terrifying
picture and as I'm typing that stuff
because I'm the typist he says put in
cream put in cream I said what cream
it's just right right down cream I said
what's what cream who are you talking
about just put it just put it put it do
me a favor just put it so I've typed in
cream well it turns out while we're
typing that scene he's already listening
to the music I didn't know what I was
going to get but then when I saw the
Russians I saw that gleam in his eyes
and I sink that to the guitar from
Sunshine Of Love right to that point so
now I can't interpret that I can't tell
you where that it's all intuitive it's
all part of whatever comes out of him